merci
allez les gars allez allez donc surtout
avant même de commencer à échantillonner un chameau
l'approche est la chose la plus importante que
vous devez faire
[Musique]
donc une fois que le chameau est retenu vous pouvez
aller de l'avant pour échantillonner ce que vous voulez
si vous voulez  du sang alors vous allez surtout
pour la jubilation
mais si vous êtes sur les écouvillons la plupart du temps
vous échangez le
nez ou la direction
[Applaudissements] [
Applaudissements]
donc [
Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai réalisé qu'il y avait un certain nombre d'
anticorps dans les
échantillons de chameau, alors nous avons dit est-ce que nous venons de
nous poser une question parce que la masse
est une maladie génétique
[Musique]
alors
vous